this is the largest lead of the game
Lillard bio Westbrook this is terrific
pursuit by Westbrook
to stay in the play not to stop and then
spikes it out about stay in the play not
to stop and then spikes it out about you
can almost say they've been mucking up
the whole game the way they played so
physical basketball from the opening the
Vantage of the smaller Damion Lillet no
he'll gets the contact and the bass
pushing up to 16
Portland cut it down to five and it
stacks up to 12 is Larry
[Applause]
[Music]
scam has really gone up a couple of
notches and it was Merlin's Noel Bullard
offense Westbrook well falling away
don't play you one-on-one get to your
spot backs in the smaller Villa elevates
knocks it down tells the baby go sleep
shirt or pass deflected ran back out
Westbrook Westbrook for three
look at this event he had to take it he
said you know I said I talked about
using every bit of the shot clock how
about this by Russ he continues where
you see the intensity there